We'll learn more from
these startups later.
Before we continue let's introduce
ourselves my name is Amir Shevat and
I work in Google developer relations,
I have mentored and
worked with many product managers and
founders across the world and
was an entrepreneur myself
before joining Google.
Throughout this course
I'll interview experts and
share my own advice on how
to build great products.
>> And I'm Chris.
I'm a course developer at Udacity.
Throughout this course I'll be
interviewing start-ups, explaining
different topics, and describing how
you can complete the final project.
>> We're excited to show you how
to build great products, and
can't wait to see what you do.